what's up everyone welcome back to the
supper suite at Tiff 2022 I've got the
team behind one of my favorite movies at
this Festival here right now who you
mean it adore your film this is the team
behind Wildflower congratulations thank
you so much thank you I mean it from the
bottom of my heart that you're gonna
have to do this a million times while
you're at this Festival but for everyone
out there who does not know what
Wildflower is yet can you give us a
brief synopsis if you're moving yeah
Wildflower is about
um B Johnson who Kiernan plays who is
basically trying to decide whether or
not she should leave to go to college or
stay and
um you know kind of take care of the
household and look after her parents who
are cognitively challenged Rock Solid
description right there to add that can
you tell us a little bit about your
connection with the inspiration for this
film and also maybe why a scripted
feature felt like the best way to get
the story out to the world yeah this
started with a um it was actually a
little short that I had done for my
niece so it's based on a true story and
it was really inspired by my niece's
situation
um my sister-in-law was born with
um a mental disability and so
um the piece was meant to help her get
into college which it did and then we
decided there's so much joy and so much
laughter and happiness and
um and hope with this family that I
wanted to kind of do it in a narrative
and use the you know this real family as
an Inspiration Point you very very much
feel exactly what you just described
while you're watching it I mean it
Kiernan for you I assume you met
Christina right uh I've never met
Christina in person has she seen the
movie she has she has now okay good she
loved it and yeah
yeah the ton and cried so yeah she has
of course oh my so I was so taken by her
in the documentary though and just the
immense amount of
strength and maturity that she had
and still has I would assume I imagine
there has to be a million answers to
this question but maybe is there like a
chief quality of hers that you noticed
in the documentary that you kind of
wanted to be an anchor to your
performance like one specific thing you
wanted to shine through no matter what I
think there is just such a sort of
specific
Drive in the way that she spoke
um and there was a a wise Beyond her
years-ness that I really loved because I
think you can be mature and grounded and
independent and thoughtful but also be a
kid and that's what I really wanted to
find and be was sort of this uh Duality
more on one hand she's
incredibly responsible and has to be
responsible for a lot more than a lot of
people her age are but at the same time
is still finding herself and growing up
so that kind of balance was what was so
so so compelling to me in in the
character
grow a similar question uh Dash and
Samantha to you with uh Mike and Sheila
what is the quality of them that you
wanted to make sure was really present
and forceful in your own performances
for me I really wanted to focus on the
love that they share but also the
innocence and the childlike Wonder with
the world and how easy it is to just
love everybody ever for you dash
um I have way deeper answers that I
really want to go into that I'm not
allowed to but
um
this is an unusual tale uh one of
um dysfunctional family that I believe
we can all uh agree if anybody says that
they're functional family 100 percent
then they're lying
um but it didn't take on on what that is
and and ultimately
that yes love is all there is it doesn't
matter when it comes down to it that
that's
um
the visibility that you have within your
family and that growth and that Arc is
what's most important and I believe Matt
um really brought that to life
other major relationship in this movie
is between your characters and their
friendship to seeing towards the end
that I want to touch on so badly we're
not spoiling anything here maybe to
tease how they evolved throughout the
film what do you think each of them need
from each other at this point in their
lives in order to to grow and mature
I think
oftentimes when you grow up
being friends with someone you both find
yourself evolving and growing into new
versions of yourselves and then sort of
butting up against each other without
really knowing what's up or why and to
me that's sort of where we find the and
the uh it's in this moment in time where
they're both thinking about their future
and completely overwhelmed and maybe
don't have all the words to articulate
what they mean to each other but they
end up finding it yeah I feel like a big
part of our friendship
kind of
like the storyline
um
I think my character needed independence
from B and I think that's something that
we touched upon in the movie and I also
thought that
um
like what I kept in mind while I was
filming was
regardless of how long you've been
friends with someone like if they're
growing up you know feeling like they've
grown up a little bit too fast or coming
from a dysfunctional family like you
never truly understand like what they're
going through and I feel like
Nia doesn't really completely get be in
that way like no matter you know like
probably we've been friends it's like
Elementary School probably that's how I
would place it
yeah I totally get that all right dash
I'm coming back your way because I
always love talking about the value of a
good scene partner and you have some
very special ones that are sitting on
this couch right now so can you
highlight something about each of them
that you really appreciated as the scene
partner that maybe helped you access
something in your own performance that
you wouldn't have been able to without
them
well I would start with you but I have
to start with her and I don't have to
but because
um
um you know I there's there's these
sayings and I will totally talk talking
points but uh of about being a
neurodivergent and uh neurodiverse and
uh for me I grew up with Tourette
syndrome and uh it has subsided over the
years but there's things that that I
have within me and that over time I've
allowed to Foster and uh make easier in
my work so working with Sam who was kind
of like a the rookie on the set and
being but I I to me I wish that I had
I'm not trying to Big up myself but I
wish that I had somebody that when I was
excited and young and ready to to blow
and wanted to do everything that I
thought that I've been planning on in my
obsessive compulsive brain that I had
somebody to talk to and instantly she
and I connected on that level and so it
was really
um it was really easy in that way and
she took to it very quickly and this one
what can I tell you you just put us in a
car and
we're um you know it's it it it's
it's love it's Pro and uh I I he'll talk
until I talk about him but uh we don't
really have anything to do together
I was already hearing something uh about
you recently like I wonder if your ears
were burning because I had Abigail Cowan
on collider ladies night recently and
she just like sang your praises and how
special it is to have you a leader as a
leader and a number one on a call sheet
so know that you are making a good
impression on many of people I get lucky
with these team partners though I tell
you I
so lucky this this whole cast and
everyone's just an absolute killer
they're so Dynamic every single one with
that in mind this might be a weird
question to ask with so much of the cast
sitting here but because you get to work
with most of the people in this like a
plus Ensemble oh my gosh who's whose
process would you say is most similar to
yours where the second you hit set you
were just immediately in sync doing
exactly what felt right to you but then
who's someone else that had a different
approach to the work that may be
challenged you to adapt and try
something new really interesting I think
that Charlie Plummer and I work very
similarly we
[Music]
had had the most probably experienced
pre-shooting doing scenes because I did
a chem read with him so
maybe that was a reason why I felt like
we were sort of super in sync but I I
feel like we just sort of clicked and
got each other and it was also I think
the dynamic of the two characters lent
itself to sort of a a certain amount of
closeness and comfort that we just
really had and I don't think that's
something that you can sort of
manipulate or make up it just we got
really lucky that we had kind of genuine
chemistry and like a real piece around
each other
um and someone that works differently I
mean everyone should we didn't have time
for people to be not prepared this was
this wasn't Indie I will say and this is
not really answering your question and
it's kind of not spoiling anything
either but to be in a coma and kind of
like listen into the listening to the
most pro-pro actors that I have could
possibly dream up act over me and talk
about me was a really surreal experience
it was so great to work with them but to
also just kind of like do this the whole
time well like Gene Smart and Jackie
Weaver are going at it it blew my mind I
can't even imagine absolutely blew my
mind all right Matt so given the fact
that this was a very quick shoot was
there any particular scene that you kind
of circled and read and said I wish we
had more time to film this but then
ultimately because you had to go go you
kind of you know found that special
magic that you never would have found if
you had all the time in the world
I mean every scene I wish I had more
time but I I will say the cast was so
unbelievably incredible and talented and
so well prepared it was literally like
we got there we went we did our couple
takes literally and we were moving on I
mean it was it was the thing that
happened in what you sort of hope and
dream is that you have this magic that
you know every once in a while it's like
lightning in a bottle that happens and
we had that and we just were all in sync
and it was a family
multi-generational family movie and then
I had it you know like right before my
eyes so it was extraordinary all right
Samantha I'm coming back your way
because the first feature is a very very
big deal what is something about what it
takes to make a movie that you couldn't
believe that that's the way it works
this is maybe a little silly but oh
this is maybe a little silly but I
actually wasn't really surprised by the
process the one thing that maybe did
surprise me a little bit was how
supportive everyone was from the PA to
the sound guy to my amazing co-stars to
my director to the producers I mean they
set up a meeting before I started where
I got to meet Kiernan and dash and Alex
and I think was there anyone else there
just I think that was just but
everyone made it such a welcoming
experience it was pretty much exactly
what I've always dreamed So and I've
been dreaming of it for a very very long
time so it was the perfect first feature
for me okay I'm gonna throw another
question your way I'm gonna include you
too Canon because this is uh this is the
first feature and you know you've you've
only done a couple of projects thus far
so given the fact that you get to work
with so many incredibly talented Pros
here is there anything you saw someone
else do on this set that you're gonna
put in your back pocket and use yourself
on a future film oh my God working with
Kiernan every day was so incredible like
the moment they would call action like
there was like a switch and I know I
know that's how it should be but like
it was just like you have such a power
and it's such a force when it comes to a
scene like
um when I watched the there's like a
scene that we do in the bathroom and
it's just so like it was so good like
scenes that I wasn't even in I I was
watching the movie and I was like oh my
God
I could like talk about this all day but
Gene could just turn on the tears
never knew apparently
um for the best
she is yeah she's great she at dream mom
um for me I think just the rehearsal
process like I rehearsed and rehearsed
and rehearsed at home and I like made my
friends Rebecca Kennedy and Sue Anne
Payne who are fellow actors rehearsed
with me like a hundred times but then I
got there and I started working with
people and they just do it they just
like do it the first time then and there
and I really would like to have some of
that uh free willingness to like just do
it as you go and like actually find the
moment in the moment but also Kiernan
and Jean and Brad got coffee trucks so
that's maybe like a couple movies down
the line but I just loved how generous
everybody was I will say though I mean
there's such a spontaneity in in
Samantha's performance and working with
you that was one of my favorite Parts
was that I always felt like the the
scene changed every single take in a way
that felt really beautiful and right and
I I love when things feel surprising and
I I I feel like working with
with you was a complete Delight in that
department and every department but you
do
and the credit to Matt for letting us do
those improvs they were some of the most
fun let us improv a lot and I was really
thankful that he let us do that
I'm gonna have to let you all go soon
but before I do I want to squeeze in one
question about a future project for you
because I'm always here to support
anything Sasha Pearl River is attached
to can you tell me anything about it's
totally killer that's going to make it
stand out as a horror comedy especially
on the heels of movies like freaky and
happy death day what is that movie gonna
give us that we love so much in those
but also make it stand out it's really
fun
um it's
it's a nostalgic literal trip to the
past I mean there's as a time travel
based horror movie which is a lot of
Concepts in one but somehow it it really
works I uh I go back to sort of uh I
time travel to change the course of
events and hopefully save some things
that happen in the present day and I
will say it's like I had so much fun
filming it it's really just Broad and
big and campy but it also has like a
real true heart to it I think people are
going to be really entertained but also
hopefully moved I mean it's kind of like
a mother-daughter story at the end of
the day that's sort of the the motivator
for it all in a way that I think can
really Target some heartstrings whilst
you're going on this journey with me and
it also just has all the fun elements of
or like it's got the mask it's got scary
things popping out left and right you
don't know what's gonna happen and it's
just like it's kind of delightful and
fun in that sort of way I I think it's
gonna be
I have all the faith in the world I was
already sold on that movie but that
description just made me even more
positive like the proper ladies Vibes
too I mean there's scrunchies and and
leg warmers and the whole nine yards
this is all exactly what I needed so
much eyeshadow scrunchies and leg
warmers I'm in I'm going I didn't hear
anything you said before that
all day I will as soon as the world gets
to see it so I'm gonna tell everybody
out there keep an eye out for this movie
trust me thank you so much for watching
this interview we will see you soon with
more from Tiff 2022. thank you thank you